como llegué aquí
si les digo que el perder me trajo a
este lugar me creerían seguramente me
van a decir que te haga nada lo dijiste
mal yo le diría no sin que se dice decir
perder y ustedes me dijiste irían no
vale perder te lleva a cosas malas total
estamos tan acostumbrados a escuchar que
perder es lo peor que nos puede pasar y
es algo muy malo que hay que evitar a
toda costa que lo vimos siempre y
realmente el hecho de perder no es lo
que nos aterra o lo que nos da mucho
miedo es el sentimiento que viene con
eso es la sensación de esforzarte tanto
por lograr algo prepararte todos los
días por ese sueño por ese objetivo que
el momento en el que no llega y
fracasamos sentimos que el mundo se nos
viene abajo eso es lo que realmente nos
pone mal y estoy de acuerdo con todos es
un sentimiento que no se los deseo a
nadie sin embargo considero que no es lo
peor que nos puede pasar
yo decidí tomar hacer la profesión que
más te expone al fracaso decidí ser
deportista en una disciplina muy
complicada que es la esgrima y llevo más
de 15 años en esto 13 años ya en la
selección nacional y créanme cuando les
digo que he perdido muchísimas más veces
de las que he ganado en una ocasión en
el 2011 se venía el evento del año no no
solo del año de la temporada no solo la
temporada de todos los tiempos se venían
los juegos panamericanos de
guadalajara-2011 este evento solamente
se realiza cada 4 años y cambia de sedes
y es una justa donde todos los atletas
de toda américa se reúne para demostrar
quién es el mejor nos tocó en casa nos
tocó en guadalajara y todo méxico estaba
loco se detuvo y dijo hay que
prepararnos hay que estar muy bien al
100 para este evento y así fue nos
fuimos a entrenar a diferentes países
en uno de esos nos tocó ir a cuba los
cubanos los atletas cubanos se
distinguían muchísimo por ser super
aguerridos fuertes no solamente
mentalmente hablo literalmente
físicamente son muy fuertes los cubanos
y también un poco agresivos en el
combate son atletas muy completos nos
pusimos a entrenar las jornadas de
entrenamiento eran super cansadas eran
de 4 a 5 horas diarias era exhausto sin
aire acondicionado era muy difícil para
nosotros adaptarnos ahí conocí a una
chica que se convirtió en mi pesadilla
porque siempre siempre me ganaba cada
entrenamiento era perder perder perder
literal me volví su hija y ella se
volvió mi coco no cuando dicen no pues
ya es mi mamá no está super enojada
siempre me iba muy molesta los
entrenamientos pensando que ella siempre
se salía con la suya y yo no hacía nada
y me empecé a frustrar muchísimo estas
veces que te invade el coraje y dije
bueno
qué tengo que hacer no respire un poco
me puse a visualizar me puse a analizar
la situación empecé a ver en que ella
era fuerte y porque me estaba ganando y
porque yo no ganaba en que era yo débil
empecé a buscar esas debilidades para
convertirlas en fortalezas y tomarlas
como oportunidades para abordar sus
debilidades que si me voy a preparar y
me empecé a motivar ya saben esas veces
que te levantas en las mañanas
desenterró aquí y así y que éste dice el
día le voy a ganar y estaba súper
decidida era una motivación para mí
constante el hecho de ir a ganarle pues
bueno se llegó el último día de
entrenamiento y nos funciona hacer una
dinámica donde teníamos que combatir a
15 toques simulando una competencia real
cuando tú llegas a 15 toques ya ganaste
o que entonces me tocó ella
pero me temo que me puse el chinito de
acordarme estaba súper emocionada estaba
preparada dije 'voy pues no ya hice un
montón de cosas ya me puse entrenar ya
la estudie estoy lista para ganarle
empezó el combate
empecé a ganarle y en ese momento dije
bueno yo ya esto es mío ya la hice hoy
es mi idea estaba súper contenta porque
le iba a ganar por fin de repente ella
saca el colmillo me alcanza no solamente
me alcanza si no me da la vuelta bueno
pues se me empezó a llenar de nervios se
empareja la cosa nos fuimos a la recta
final estábamos cerca del 15 le iba
ganando 14 13 estaba a un punto de
ganarle a uno y quien cree que pasó
y creen que pasó
me dio la vuelta y me gano no puede ser
o sea sea
o sea no podía creerlo estaba tan
enojada dije me he preparado tanto todos
los días he venido he venido más
temprano hasta he comido mejor porque
dije no esto tal vez no está estorbando
me estaba preparando en serio para que
las cosas no resultarán pues bueno no me
quedaba de otra no iba a cambiar la
situación definitivamente eso ya estaba
en el pasado y se berrinche en otro lado
porque el entrenamiento yo bien intensa
no es ese entrenamiento al matrimonio
está súper molesta pues me calme dije
qué pasó qué pasó
bueno empecé a ver que me anticipé un
poco ya estaba cantando victoria es el
día que voy a ganar estaba súper
emocionada no me anticipé ok y luego
empecé a ver que estaba cometiendo otros
errores tipos con los que había cometido
anteriormente con ella dije bueno es que
lo volví a hacer mal esto me trajo estos
problemas bueno no puedo hacer nada me
queda el aprendizaje la experiencia
vamos a darle la vuelta a la hoja ya me
voy a méxico ya ver qué pasa no así fue
me fui a méxico
era el evento ya ya estábamos en juegos
panamericanos de guadalajara-2011 para
lo que nos habíamos preparado tanto nos
fuimos a varios países llegamos a cuba
se hizo todo súper bien yo estaba más
preparada más fuerte más rápida que
nunca de esas veces que dices hoy es el
día hoy es el día me levanté con el pie
derecho y empezó la competencia empecé a
ganar no gane casi todos los combates me
clasifiqué muy bien me clasifiqué como
una de las más fuertes y salió la
clasificación no dije voy a verla ahora
voy a ver la hoja me puse a ver la hoja
y empecé a contar yo era la número tres
de la clasificación
ok número 3 1 2 3 y alelí hernández y es
como una llave donde el uno se va con el
16 el 2 con el 15 el 3 con el 14 el
cuadro así sucesivamente se hace una
llave f y se hacen las eliminaciones
estos dije pues me va con la 14 entonces
empecé a buscar 14 14 14 14
vamos a ver país de procedencia
cuba sea
tranquilo
apellido
ya tu sabes no ya ya eso ya creo que se
cuenta solo pues que está estaba súper
nerviosa empecé a hiperventilar así de
que no puede ser es que es que ella
siempre me gana entonces vine a perder y
todo lo que hice me empecé a abrumar con
muchísimas ideas empecé este para que me
preparo tanto me empecé a derrotar yo
solita con todo lo que me venía a la
cabeza hasta que dije bueno pero aunque
me pongo una cachetada a ver te calmas
te calmas ya por favor
acá me diálogo me decía a ver
ya la conoces
bueno si ya la conoces ya sabes cómo es
ella como eres tú cuáles son sus
fortalezas cuáles son sus debilidades
pues aprovéchalo
lo tienes tienes la experiencia ya lo
viviste toma todo eso que ya pasó y
aplícalo hoy hoy es el gran día
si tienes razón ya te preparas decisión
o no sí sí me preparé esta licitación o
no sí sí estoy lista bueno ya me dio así
común un ataque sea de la legio que
estoy preparada estoy lista para lo que
sea y esto fue lo que pasó
play por favor
toque verde luz verde es toque para ella
luz roja esto que para mí el juez que
está enfrente decide de quién es la
acción empecé a ganarle 12
y después me alcanzó
y no solo me alcanzó sino que también
me dio la vuelta
le suena familiar
nos acercamos a la recta final después
íbamos muy cerrados le iba ganando 14 13
estaba a un toque de ganar y que creen
que pasó
leganés por fin me gané era el día el
momento el lugar preciso para haber
ganado parecía que todo se había
acomodado para yo haber tenido una
lección super importante y llegar al día
importa al mar al día ya sabe el evento
para hacerlo lo mejor posible con toda
la experiencia y tener la revancha que
tanto había deseado y no solo la
revancha contra ella sino la revancha
contra mí y mis pensamientos y todas
estas cosas que venían a mi cabeza esa
es mi historia
ahora tu historia quiero que recuerden
un momento una situación donde hayan
fracasado puede ser desde lo más simple
que a todos nos ha pasado como reprobar
una materia si a todos ha pasado no no
no no vas a ni verdad
reprueban la materia como emprender un
negocio y que éste no funcione que haya
quebrado obtener una relación por
ejemplo y que también no no haya
resultado ya la tiene cualquier cosa
donde hayan apostado y lo hayan perdido
todo
lo tienen todos
no escucho
aunque muy bien vamos a un experimento
vamos a empezar a sentir lo primero que
se siente cuando esto pasa son dos
emociones muy fuertes
la primera es
el enojo la siguiente es la frustración
la tristeza no viene en estas dos muy
importantes bien en una primera que otra
o vienen en combo no el enojo y la
tristeza yo no lo primero que hago yo es
enojarme y empiezo a maldecir empiezo a
decir hoy no puede ser no puede ser no
puede ser
a mí se me vienen en combo después viene
la impotencia
el ver que lo he hecho está hecho lo
dicho está dicho que las cosas no se
pueden cambiar que no se puede regresar
el tiempo y que tu cabeza suena común y
si hubiera subiera y se hubiera todos
los hubieras posible pero pues eso no va
a cambiar después viene el peor el que
más te destruye que es la
autoflagelación
es que estoy bien tonta que no debí
haberlo intentado es que para que lo
hice porque me arriesgue me hubiera
quedado en mi casa viendo series nada
nada de esto hubiera pasado hubiera
estado bien agusto es que no sirvo para
esto no sirvo para nada no
y si ese es el sentimiento que nos llega
después de todo este revoltijo de
emociones de pensamientos que van que
vienen se abren dos caminos
el primero es
a la tostada
lo censure es porque me vayan a cancelar
no me cáncer le importa baja
no me cancelen todo bien pero es lo
primero que pensamos la verdad si lo
pensamos así y este es el camino más
fácil es el que tomamos con lo que
sentimos y no con lo que pensamos es la
más fácil como para decir no sabes que
no sirve para esto ya me harté estoy
cansado esto no me hace feliz me agobia
me estresa ojo hay cosas donde por
ejemplo el trabajo que estamos haciendo
no nos gusta ni nos apasionan y no
sabemos de qué estamos haciendo no vemos
a nuestra familia esto nos está
enfermando nos está provocando ansiedad
todo menos felicidad todo menos sueños
ok
qué bueno que se dieron cuenta ok hay
que cambiar de objetivos pero si en
cambio son cosas que te motivan que te
vibran que te tienen día con día
trabajando esforzándote es el sueño esto
no va a ser el mejor camino te lo puedo
asegurar
y viene de este lado otro camino que se
llama
qué pasó bájale tu drama
camatte por favor
ya no dejas de sentir y comienzas a
pensar
entonces en este empiezas a hacer
al hacer para atrás el casete
y esto y algo
híjole no pues si eso que dije sí sí me
pase no si definitivamente si me pasa si
no no debe haberlo dicho y luego le das
otra vez vueltas
al casete y ves y dices me pongo esto
porque estoy en modo audiovisual ya
sabes en el caserío
le das vuelta al cáncer y dices no sí
pues esto que hice me veo bien débil si
es que me faltaba más fuerza me faltaba
estar más entrenado más preparado más
estudiado definitivamente hay algo que
cambiarlo esto que pasó ya no lo puedo
cambiar sin embargo veo una oportunidad
de ahí para mejorar lo que muy bien
después de ese aprendizaje viene la
experiencia
y está yo la llamo él
con medio el colmillo a una persona con
mi ayuda es esa persona que sabe que por
aquí por aquí no es por aquí si es por
acá está fácil por acá está bien difícil
esa persona que se la sabe de todas
todas lo que se vuelve experta en un
tema en particular y que incluso es una
persona muy respetada en ocasiones hasta
temida que no agua si es que es bien con
mi ayuda de aguas se la sabe de todas ya
pasó por eso no se la vas a vender tan
fácil esas personas ven siempre la
oportunidad ve como aprovecharse de
todas las situaciones buenas y malas y
viven como a como dárselas a su favor
con decirles que hay algunos que toman
toda esa experiencia y la convierten en
conferencias ted ex imagínense no hay de
todas clases colmilludos hay contestó la
primera pregunta que qué hago aquí bueno
como llegué aquí así me trajo esta
experiencia y bueno estas personas
cambian su perspectiva tienen una forma
de pensar muy distinta
toda su percepción es
positiva no dejan de preguntarse los por
qué y comienzan a preguntarse para que
cuando tú te preguntas por qué tus ojos
se van hacia el pasado y empiezan a
repasar y empiezan a encontrar excusas
no no fui porque pues me sentía bien
cansados no pues le contesté así porque
me hizo enojar no empiezas a encontrar
excusas y cosas que no te van a llevar a
ningún lado porque ya está allá pero
cuando te preguntas para qué para qué me
pasó esto en dices nuevo pues para
aprender no pues para ver los detalles
no para ver que me hacía falta hacer un
poquito más de ejercicio para estar más
fuerte para estar más estudiado para
prepararme para una situación
seguramente más complicada y aquí es
donde es importante preguntarse para qué
regresando con ustedes a su historia
a su momento de fracasos los
sentimientos si ustedes tomaron el
camino el primero que ya saben cómo se
llama no le quiero decir 9 censura si
tomaban el primer camino seguramente le
hicieron así
ahí nos vemos miren me tapo un ojo me
tapo el otro y nada que ver no quiero
saber nada cancelado o cancelado
cancelado ya no me interesa es algo que
no quiero en mi vida no y en vez de este
quedarte con algo sacarle provecho esa
situación simplemente eliminar
ok los que tomaron el otro camino
seguramente
empezaron a trabajar y empezaron a
esforzarse se empezaron a levantar
temprano empezaron a echarle más ganas a
ponerse más fuertes a estudiar más a ver
los detalles a hacerse perfeccionistas a
ver que esto les va a resultar y que
esto no hacer más experimentados más
inteligentes
ganaron de haber perdido
seguramente si ganaron de haber perdido
y definitivamente no intentamos las
cosas buscando perder
pero ganar perdiendo nos va a acercar
más a eso que tanto deseamos muchas
gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]